[Musik]
meine Lieben Zuschauer in unserem
gestrigen ersten Teil dieses
zweiteiligen Videos über den
brigochienaufstand haben wir euch
erklärt was genau zur Meuterei des
Wagner Chefs gegen den Kreml geführt hat
und wir haben euch versprochen dass wir
im heutigen zweiten Teil sorgfältig
klären werden welche genauen Folgen
dieser megafail für das Regime Wladimir
Putins haben wird solltet ihr noch nicht
gesehen haben könnt ihr euch den ersten
Teil jetzt ansehen indem ihr den Link
oben rechts hinter dem e-symbol folgt
damit ihr alle wichtigen Zusammenhänge
versteht wir bereiten gerade ein Video
für euch vor indem wir uns ansehen
werden welche Clans und macht
Gruppierungen sich in Russland bereits
darauf vorbereiten die Nachfolge
Vladimir Putin zu übernehmen wie Sie
schon jetzt Ihre Messer wessen
gegeneinander kämpfen und sich in
Stellung bringen also Abo nicht
vergessen um es ja nicht zu verpassen
heute schauen wir uns aber erstmal genau
an ob ihr Hoffnung auf ein baldiges Ende
der Ära Putin überhaupt gerechtfertigt
ist was hat sich mit brigosch ins
muttererei an Punkt den Status geändert
schnallt Euch jetzt gut an wir begeben
uns auf eine stürmische Fahrt in eine
neue Realität das einige Video hat
übrigens in kognie möglich gemacht ein
ganz besonderer Sponsor der euch nämlich
aktiv vor Datenmissbrauch durch
sogenannte data Broker schützen kann
data Broker sind datenmakler die eure
persönlichen Daten überall im Netz
abgreifen und danach nicht nur als
seriöse Unternehmen verkaufen sondern
auch oft an Betrüger diese Betrüger
bombardieren uns dann mit unerwünschten
Anrufen SMS und E-Mails oder versuchen
uns auszunehmen leider haben wir keine
Kontrolle darüber an wen unsere Daten
verkauft werden aber die data Broker
sind gesetzlich verpflichtet unsere
Daten zu löschen wenn wir sie dazu
auffordern das Problem dabei es gibt
Tausende von ihnen und oft ist der
Antragsprozess absichtlich kompliziert
gestaltet deswegen resignieren viele
Menschen einfach und lassen den ganzen
Schmuck passiv über sich ergeben der
Sponsor dieses Videos in kognietet genau
dafür jedoch eine Lösung in übernimmt
die Aufgabe bei den data broken
aufzuräumen und ihre Anträge so stellen
um uns vor Betrugsversuchen zu schützen
du meldest dich bei inkognini einfach an
beauftragt sie in deinem Namen die
lösch-anträge durchzusetzen und verfolgt
dann bequem auf einem übersichtlichen
Dashboard wie deine Daten nach und nach
aus Netz verschwinden ohne einen solchen
Service wäre es für einen normalen
Menschen nahezu unmöglich diese
Löschanträge selbst zu bearbeiten und
sich vor Betrug zu schützen also du was
gutes für deine datenhygiene und schau
dir inkognit über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung mal an außerdem mit
dem Promo-Code politik.de erhältst du
auch noch 60% Rabatt wenn du zu den
ersten 100 gehörst die ihr Nutzen und
falls Du uns etwas Nettes tun möchtest
ebenfalls in der Beschreibung bei diesem
Video findest du ein Spenden Link mit
dem du unsere Arbeit auf freiwilliger
Basis unterstützen kannst wir danken dir
schon mal im voraus so und wenn wir das
alles erledigt haben lasst uns wieder
zum Thema dieses Videos kommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
während des russischen Krieges in der
Ukraine sind die wagnergruppe und vor
allem ihr Anführer immer mehr in den
Vordergrund getreten als trouble Shooter
und Leiter von Großeinsätzen das
Unmögliche möglich machen um das
russische Militär von seinem fluchen
namens Bach Mut erlösen sollte stieg er
zum Messias seiner Truppen der
Nationalisten und auch viele regulärer
Soldaten auf von dieser Position aus
wurde er dann zur Geißel der russischen
Militärführung und neuerdings sogar zum
Schutzpatron der Armen russischen
Soldaten zu diesem Zweck hat er nicht
gezögert am laufenden Band Videos
aufzunehmen in denen er die Opferung
russische Soldaten verurteilt er hat
äußerst mir jeden Tag zusammen Geschenke
an ihre widmen und Mütter verteilt und
vor allem hat er Wahrheiten über den
Krieg ausgesprochen die sich sonst
niemand in Russland zu sagen traute das
alles sind Dinge die sich in Russland
aktuell sehr gut verkaufen rigoschen hat
seine Popularität vervielfacht seht euch
nur an wie er Rostock unter Beifall und
Jubel verließ nachdem der
Waffenstillstand mit der Regierung
vereinbart worden war
aber warum so werdet ihr euch fragen hat
Putin diesen Mann so lange erlaubt der
hat populär zu werden und seine
Regierung so unerbittlich anzugreifen
nun einer der Gründe war dass er mit all
diesen Anschuldigungen dem russischen
Präsidenten selbst geholfen hat
er spielte eigentlich nach Putins Noten
mit anderen Worten als langjähriger
Freund und Verbündeter Putins hatte er
es auf Leute wie scheuge und geraten
abgesehen dies entsprach der üblichen
Teiler und Herrscher
rivalisierungsstrategie Putins und er
beschuldigte sie als die wahren
Schuldigen an der schlechten Lage nicht
den Präsidenten dieser sein oder das
arme Opfer ihrer korrupten
Machenschaften gemeinsam mit dem ebenso
armen Volk ne ist das nicht eine
rühriges Bild der Präsident und sein
Volk in einem Boot auf derselben Seite
doch in seinem Video vom Freitag den 23
juni sollte Gregorian eine rote Linie
überschreiten denn es ist die eine Sache
sich zu beschweren dass es ein Munition
mangelt und eine ganz andere offen zu
sagen dass sie Argumente
zurechtfertigung der Invasion eine
Schwindel waren er hat aus seiner
Position überragende Glaubwürdigkeit
Putins heiligen Gral einfach auf dem
harten Boden der Realität zerschmettert
und deshalb hat Putin im Fernsehen
gesagt pregorian sei ein Verräter der
aus aller härteste bestraft werden
müssen das Problem er hat seine Aussage
de facto zurücknehmen müssen und auch
die strafrechtliche Verfolgung deswegen
zumindest offiziell eingestellt und das
ist ein Problem denn es macht allen
deutlich das Russlands oberster Mann
nicht mehr über so viel Macht verfügt
wie früher ich muss mit Bitterkeit
zugeben dass die Russische Föderation
ihrem endgültigen und unwiderruflichen
Tod einen Schritt näher gekommen ist von
nun an gibt es in der Russischen
Föderation zwei Präsidenten den
königlichen Präsidenten und den
Inhaftierten Vizepräsidenten Wladimir
Putin das Hauptziel des zweiten
Präsidenten wird es sein sich regelmäßig
an den königlichen Präsidenten zu wenden
und zwar in Knie in der Position mit der
Frage was möchtest du jetzt gehen ihr
viktorovic niemals nicht einmal in
meinem schlimmsten Albtraum hätte ich
mir vorstellen können dass ich diese
Schande und den Tod meines Landes
erleben würde Viktor emanovic Alexis
ehemaliges Mitglied des obersten Service
der UdSSR und ehemalige Abgeordneter
staatsblume der Russischen Föderation
heute hat die Welt gesehen dass
Russlands Herren nichts mehr unter
Kontrolle haben es herrscht das totale
Chaos wo Leute mir selinski ja es stimmt
das pregorsche nach der getroffenen
Vereinbarung erstmal nach Weißrussland
ins Exil gehen wird aber bedeutet das
dass er seinen Einfluss aufgeben wird
wird er endgültig aufgeben die Fäden in
Russland zu ziehen nun ja daran gibt es
ernsthafte Zweifel um seine Autorität
wiederherzustellen wird Putin also
irgendein Weg finden müssen Prägung zu
belangen und da die Möglichkeit mit dem
Fahrrad ja schon verbrannt ist hat er
sich nun auf Korruption eingeschossen
tja ausgerechnet Korruption wenn das für
ihn mal nicht nach hinten losgeht aber
dazu kommen wir noch der Kreml hat als
Vergeltungsmaßnahme auf jeden Fall schon
mal pregorians Mediengruppe geschlossen
die unter anderem eine trollfarbe treibt
ums soziale Medien auf der ganzen Welt
zu manipulieren na das tut uns aber echt
Leid nicht außerdem hat das
Verteidigungsministerium die lukrativen
Verträge mit brigoches Catering Firma
Concord gekündigt aber mit all dem
dürfte der Wagner brauchst sowieso
gerechnet haben klar ist das alles war
ein großer rückschlagverbotin der
russische Präsident hat ein Desaster in
der Ukraine verursacht er verliert den
Krieg und jetzt auch noch das schaut
euch an was der russische Journalist
Michael Sieger im Januar sagte Russland
Präsident Vladimir Putin hat anscheinend
endlich erkannt dass der Krieg in der
Ukraine einen gefährlichen Konkurrenten
für seine Macht geschaffen hat ihr Genie
pregorien und natürlich gehen die
folgenden Meuterei noch viel weiter
putin ist nicht mehr so furchterregend
wie früher und das ist das Schlimmste
was einem Autokraten passieren kann in
Regimen wie diesen beruht die Macht des
Präsidenten im Wesentlichen auf seine
Fähigkeit Angst zu verbreiten sich
Respekt zu verschaffen und abweichenden
Meinungen zu bestrafen und jetzt konnten
wir erleben wie eine Organisation von
25000 sollten dann ein wichtiges
Operationszentrum des Ukraine Feldzugs
eingenommen hat und dann auf Moskau
vorrückte ohne das etwas passiert ist
und vergessen nicht dass im März 2024
Wahlen stattfinden werden
von den ersten Stunden an ließ der
pregosch in Aufstand Putin schwach
aussehen und fähig sich selbst und die
Kräfte die seinen Krieg führen zu
kontrollieren als ich wagnerstruppen
Moskau näherten verstärkte sich diese
Eindruck noch ich finde die Tatsache
dass dies von Luca Schenker moderiert
wurde äußerst peinlich braucht Putin
jemand anderen um seine Probleme zu
lösen ja wir wissen es die Wahlen in
Russland sind noch gefälschter als die
WM Wahl in Katara aber trotzdem wir
werden sehen ob Putin es schafft und ob
er sich zur Wiederwahl stellen kann das
große Versprechen das große Engagement
des russischen Präsidenten war es immer
Russland aus der Anarchie der 90er Jahre
zu retten und seine große Liebe
herzustellen aber jetzt ist das alles
zerbrochen
auf Abruf
Russland ist nicht stärker seine Armee
wird immer schwächer der Wohlstand im
Land schwindet die großen Oligarchen
verlieren und zu allem Überfluss ist das
Chaos so groß dass ein Warlord in aller
Ruhe durch das Land spazieren und drohen
kann die Hauptstadt zu besetzen ohne
dass ihm etwas passiert im Gegenteil
statt wie schon vorher beschlossen auf
der kompletten Eingliederung Wagners in
die reguläre Armee zum ersten 26.2023 zu
bestehen darf Wagner weiterhin existiert
nur dass das Hauptquartier eben Nachweis
Russland verlegt wird wohlgemerkt von
dort aus ist man in Moskau schneller als
von Rostock am dornrikaschutz Truppen
bekommen nun als Belohnung für ihre
Meuterei die Wahl zwischen Militär und
Wagner in Weißrussland und wo auch die
Putin dann bei Bedarf auch wieder gegen
die Ukraine einsetzen könnte denn backt
ist in der aktuellen defensivphase wird
der Wagener druckt mit seinen blutforst
Taktiken so wie so nicht benötigt falls
Punkte jedoch vor hat irgendwann wieder
in die Offensive zu gehen werden die
erfahrenen Kämpfer bitter fehlen ich
erinnere euch daran dass diese Gruppe in
den offensiv-operation seit über einem
Jahr eine Schlüsselrolle gespielt
Wagner war ein Jahr lang das einzige
erfolgreiche Element der russischen
Invasion und ihr Erfolg war auch sehr
begrenzt und konzentrierte sich auf eine
kleine Stadt und ihre Taktiken waren
selbst für wagenersche Standards
barbarisch aber wenigstens erreichten
sie etwas das vermochte die russische
Armee nicht jede Wagner Angehörige die
also keinen Bock haben zur russischen
und glaub mir die Top Leute hatten sehr
gute Gründe bei Wagner zu sein und eben
nicht in der regulären Armee werden nun
in Belarus ihre Zelte aufschlagen damit
will man sie quasi von der Straße holen
damit sie keine Dummheiten mehr
einstellen können laut dem dortigen
Kartoffel Diktator sollen sie seine
Streitkräfte ausbilden nun ja eine nette
Beschäftigungstherapie die strategisch
kaum Sinn macht die Bilder russische
Armee braucht wahrlich keine Wagener
Expertise nur um die heimische
Opposition zu unterdrücken und sie
nachvollendete Ausbildung in
wagnerschaft fleischwellen Taktik als
Kanonenfutter durch die jahrzümpfe
radioaktiver solche Wälder und
Minenfelder gehen zu schicken wäre für
Lukas Schenker militärischer die
politische Selbstmord aber keine Angst
was konkret hinter lukaschenker
Schachzug und Wagen das Umzug nach
Belarus stecken könnte werden wir in
einem künftigen Video genau unter die
Lupe nehmen ihr dürft schon mal gespannt
sein wenn ich denke dass euch unsere
Theorie ziemlich überraschen wird also
Abo nicht vergessen auf jeden Fall ist
Putins und scheucos planen die
wagnerische Kampfkraft zum
Schnäppchenpreis weiter gegen die
Ukraine und andere Zwecke einsetzen zu
können grandios gescheitert die
Propaganda-Maschine
Überstunden schieben und Putins Image
wieder herzustellen und pregorian aus
der Erinnerung der Russen zu tilgen wie
schwer Putins die Arme Managerin zeigte
sich auch darin dass es nötig war seine
knackig braun gebrannten Doppelgänger
ganz schnell nach dagegen um sich dort
nicht nur wie ein Filmstar bejubel zu
lassen sondern auch noch ein Bad in der
Menschenmenge zu nehmen und präsidiale
Bussis an wildfremde Leute zu verteilen
klar das passt total zum keimiger Putin
der sechs Meter lange Tische braucht um
sich mit seinen Staatsgästen unterhalten
und auch mit seinem jüngsten
verzweifelten versucht pregorian
anzuschwärzen und wegen Korruption zur
verfolgen hat sich Putin eher selbst
Infos geschossen denn er hat im
Zusammenhang damit nun offen zugeben
müssen das Wagner die ganze Zeit über
vollständig vom Kreml finanziert wurde
das jahrelange narrativ des gremmels und
seiner weltweit in Medien und Politik
aktiven bezahlt und unbezahlten fünften
Kolonnen ist damit in sich
zusammengebrochen die plausible
bestreitbarkeit für Putin nicht direkt
in die massiven Verbrechen Wagners rund
um die Welt versteckt gewesen zu sein
ist dahin und das lässt wahrlich all die
Leugner und Kreml Freunde die sich
manchmal auch im Kommentarbereich bei
visualpolitik herumtreiben nun die
komplette nützliche Idioten aussehen nur
dass ihre ganze Idiotie am Ende Putin
sowieso nichts genutzt hat neben diesen
Propaganda Glaube wird Putins Geständnis
aber auch diplomatische und juristische
Konsequenzen haben er hat damit eine
Reihe von Ländern die Möglichkeit
eröffnet die russische Regierung
gerichtlich zu belangen angefangen von
der Besetzung
2014 bei der Wagner Nachweis nicht eine
Schlüsselrolle spielte bis hin zu
goldtaten in afrikanischen Ländern um
sich das Ausmaß dieses Desasters für
Moskau vor Augen zu führen Wagner wird
bereits für Kriegsverbrechen in vielen
Ländern sanktioniert und strafrechtlich
verfolgt die offizielle Position moskauz
war aber immer das Wagner nichts mit der
russischen Regierung zu tun hat ja
privat Armee in Russland gar verboten
sein daher keine Russland für die
Verbrechen Wagners nicht haftbar gemacht
werden und jetzt da der Kreml offiziell
zugegeben hat das Wagner nichts als ein
Arm des russischen Staates ist ist
Russland ebenso hoch offiziell und
rechtlich wird Dutzende von
Kriegsverbrechen direkt verantwortlich
malische Truppen und mutmaßliche
russische Kämpfer werden für Massaker
verantwortlich gemacht es gibt
erschütterte Berichte über magische
Truppen und mutmaßlich russische Söldner
die im Zentrum Marlies etwa 300 Menschen
hingerichtet haben sollen
Truppe Wagner wir legen Kriegsverbrechen
Afrika angeklagt the serenity hat
herausgefunden dass die Söldnergruppe
von der Zentralafrikanischen Republik
einen albtraumhaften Plan zur Eroberung
des Staates ausgearbeitet hat um den
nationalen Ressourcen des Landes
insbesondere Gold und Diamanten zu
plündern die geostrategische und
militärische Schwächung Russlands durch
einen Verlust Wagners ist kaum zu
unterschätzen denn ohne die Söldner wird
dem Gremmel sehr wichtige Kampfkraft
fehlen seine Ziele umzusetzen egal ob in
der Ukraine im Nahen Osten oder in
Afrika oder ist das nächste Ziel etwa
die völlige Einverleibung Weißrussland
so als Großpflaster für die
Nationalisten da ist mit der Ukraine ja
nicht geklappt hat und nächstes Jahr
waren anstehen aber im Ernst wenn diese
Wagner verwendet durch das russische
Militär absorbiert werden könnte das ein
Problem darstellen nicht nur was ihre
Moral und Motivation angeht viele
afrikanische Länder waren nicht mit
einer russischen militärprinzessin
Verstand verstanden als sie mit Wagner
einen Vertrag unterzeichnet hätten sie
wollten die in ihrem Auftrag handeln
nicht Soldaten die Moskau unterstellt
sind auch wenn mos einer überwagner
indirekt Einfluss üben konnte einige
dieser afrikanischen Staatsoberhaupt da
machen sich daher große Sorgen dass ihre
Rivalen die Situation nun ausnutzen
können was zu einem Dominoeffekt in der
Region und einem weiteren
einflussverlust für Russland führen
könnte die Aufnahme von warten
erkämpfern in die russische Armee wird
jedoch noch weitere Probleme verursachen
sie könnten Gregorian als Infiltratoren
und Schläfer Inhalte armedien
schließlich ist er unter ihnen und in
weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung ja noch
immer über aus populär viel populärer
als scheuge und Konsorten und wenn
scheuburg versuchen sollte dem
entgegenzuwirken indem er die
eingespielten wagnereinheiten
auseinanderreißt und die Männer quer
über die Armee verteilt würde er die
Kampfkraft der einzigen effektiven
offensiveinheiten die Russland noch
hatte total verbessern aber das wäre
natürlich nichts Neues in diesem Land
wie damals als im Sozialismus alles
verstaatlicht kollektiviert nivelliert
und bereit gewalzt wurde bis nichts mehr
richtig funktioniert aber die
Unterordnung Wagen also unter die
Armeeführung ist natürlich nur die
Spitze des Eisbergs denn Pute werden es
nicht darauf beruhen lassen können das
so viele Angehörige der regulären Armee
und anderer Sicherheitsorgane lange
Stunden und entschlossen darauf gewartet
haben welche Seite sich anschließen in
Differenz zusahen einfach gewähren
ließen oder sogar Sympathie für ihn
bekundeten
Putin Säuberungsaktionen beginnt mit
Kommandanten und Piloten die sich
weigerten die Truppen der wagnergruppe
zum bombardieren Russland oberster
Soldat generalvalerie grassem auf sollen
nicht mehr an Entscheidungen beteiligt
sein da der Kreml hart durchgreift
generalsergesuche wir gehen ein weiterer
ehemaliger Kommandeur der
invasionsgruppe den engen Beziehungen zu
Wagner beschäftigt werden oder seit dem
Ende des Aufstands nicht mehr gesehen
und soll von den Sicherheitsdiensten
verhört werden Brötchen wird in seiner
Armee Meeres Säuberungsaktion
durchführen müssen so wie es in Russland
historisch üblich ist diese
säuberungswellen werden nicht unbedingt
schnell erfolgen denn Putin kann sich in
diesem Moment keinen großen Schocks
innerhalb der in ihren
Verteidigungsstellungen in der Ukraine
auf dem Zahnfleisch sind Kräfte erlauben
aber er wird sich durchziehen auch wenn
es die Armee schwächen wird denn wie
immer muss das Prinzip seines Systems
nur Realität vor Kompetenz umgesetzt
werden das Problem dieses parasitäres
System am Leben zu erhalten wird immer
aufwendiger und ineffizienter seine
Lebenszeit ist beschränkt da ist
irgendwann die äußeren Ressourcen
erschöpft hat und dann automatisch in
den
übergeht die Zahl kompetenter Handlanger
schrumpt zusehend vor allem weil Putin
die gesamte Führungsstruktur nicht nur
auf unbedingt der Realität in gegenüber
sondern auch auf einem knallharten Teile
und herrscheprinzip aufgebaut hat wenn
er aber bewusst Rivalität und Misstrauen
unter seinen Untergebenen streut muss er
damit rechnen dass dieses von ihm
geschaffene toxische Umfeld auch ihn
irgendwann verschlingt und dass dieser
Moment gekommen ist hat sich jetzt
gezeigt niemand innerhalb und außerhalb
der Mauern weiß jetzt noch wen er trauen
kann und wem nicht und wem vielleicht zu
halten dass ich in seinem engsten Kreis
auch diejenigen befinden könnten die
direkt an der Wagner Rebellion beteiligt
waren es ist jedoch verdammt schwer für
ihn festzustellen wer und wie stark denn
seine Spione wissen ist auch nicht mehr
mol 3 in Russland verwischt die Grenze
zwischen Patrioten und Vertreter Putin
Ängste sind so gewaltig dass er sich
jetzt sogar bei Sitzungen der
Sicherheitsrat bewachen und abstimmen
lässt es hat ganz den anscheinend dass
einer der Gründe warum scheugo nicht
gefeuert wurde darin liegt das Putin
verzweifelt an jedem loyalen Dackel auf
den erzählen kann auch wenn das
verheerende Folgen für seine
Invasionspläne in der Ukraine hat und
auch die russischen Geheimdienste sind
nur noch ein Schatten ihrer selbst
gespalten und von Gier Eigennutz und
Gleichgültigkeit gegenüber ihrem
dienstheren zerfressen Putin konnte
weder auf sie zählen also um die
Vorbereitung der Invasion ging noch um
die Vorhersage des brigoschenaufstands
und er wird auch nicht auf die zählen
können wenn es um seine Aufklärung geht
denn es sieht ganz so aus als Kind die
meisten Informationen über Verräter von
den US-Geheimdiensten ja es handelt sich
um ein Totalversagen dass selbst dass
der US-Geheimdienst von nein eleven
übertrifft regaugen hat ist also
geschafft so gut wie alle Säulen der
putinischen Macht als Pappmache zu
entladen und gleichzeitig zu zeigen dass
sich die CIA eindeutig von den Krisen
und fehlender ja tausenden Wände erholt
hat in den letzten Jahren hatte
amerikanischen Geheimdienst
hervorragende Ergebnisse erzielt die
Spitzen des CIA hatten schon lange vor
dem Blitzkrieg und den Sieg der Taliban
gewarnt nur beiden hörte damals nicht
auf sie wussten vor allen anderen
bereits im September 2021 von den
russischen invasions in die Ukraine sie
wussten offensichtlich schon Wochen im
Voraus von Pre Gosch ins plin während
der russischen FSB und Putin davon
überrumpelt wurden als Roßdorf bereits
halb besetzt war
Mitte Juni erfuhren us-spione das Trikot
in eine bewaffnete Aktion in Russland
plante die us-geheimdienstbehörden hat
Mitte juni-information erhalten die
darauf hindeuteten dass der Chef der
Wagner Söldner jetzt gehen eine
bewaffnete Aktion gegen den russischen
verteidigungsapparat plant in den
vergangenen zwei Wochen herrschte große
Besorgnis darüber was passieren könnte
ob der russische Präsident Wladimir
Putin an der Macht bleiben würde und was
jede Instabilität für die Kontrolle des
russischen Atomwaffenarsenals bedeuten
könnte und jetzt liebe Freunde scheint
es ihr förmlich die Fäden in Russland
selbst zu ziehen ja da die narrative und
nachrichtendienstliche Lufthoheit über
das Land gewonnen zu haben
die Russen kommt und spioniert für uns
US-Geheimdienst sagt die CIA will die
Wahrheit über Russland Wissen in einem
russischen Video das über Nacht auf sein
eigenes eingerichteten telegram Kanal
veröffentlicht wurde richtet sich der
us-auslands zunächst an diejenigen die
das Leben in Russland von Präsident
Wladimir Putin satt haben der
US-Geheimdienst sucht Menschen mit
unterschiedlichem Hintergrund die in den
Bereichen Militär Geheimdienst
Diplomatie Wissenschaft oder Technik
arbeiten die Amis streuen genüsslich
Gerüchte über Verräter in Putins rein
und diese hat null Ahnung ob dies
Nebelkerzen sind oder da die Wahrheit
sein eigener Geheimdienst ist nicht in
der Lage in die Strukturen und
Verhältnis im eigenen Land zu erklären
und das ist gerade für einen zum
Diktator aufgestiegenen Geheimdienst man
eine besonders bittere schwach aber hat
jetzt bitte keine Sekunde Mitleid mit
Putin er hat sich diese Falle selbst
gestellt stellt euch vor ihr wärt ein
sd-offizier der glaubwürdige
Informationen bekommen hat die Gerüchte
bestätigen die die ciaden die Welt
streut würdet ihr diese Informationen
eurem Chef geben und sich dadurch den
Verdacht aussetzen für die Amis zu
arbeiten wäre es nicht klüger nach dem
Mikado Prinzip die Klappe halten denn
wer sich in diesem System der Paranoia
bewegt hat schon verloren der FSB war ja
schon zu Beginn der Ukraine der Krise
ein Totalausfall statt die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte zu unterwandern hatte
damalige Chef der dafür zuständigen
fünften Auslandsabteilung die dazu
vorgesehenen Mittel veruntreut und dann
an den Kreml gemeldet die russischen
Truppen könnten in Kiew mit Jubel und
blumenempfängen rechnen wir haben damals
ausführlich darüber berichtet nach dem
Fiasko mit der Invasion wurde er dann
verhaftet und die Zuständigkeit für die
Infiltration der Ukraine auf dem
militärgeheimnis gehe um übertragen und
wer leitet dort diese Operation nun der
stellvertretende Direktor unser Freund
Wladimir Alex genau jene alexejef der
einen besonders guten Draht zu Gregorian
hatte einen so guten Draht dass er ihn
raus drauf über die Entführung von
scheuburg und gerassimovic aber dieser
zynismus ist wieder ein Zufall noch ein
Einzelfall er ist die logische
Konsequenz eines Systems aus Lügen
Misstrauen Paranoia und Apathie das
Putin über Jahre aufgebaut hat und auf
dem er seine Macht gründet die ständige
Bereitstellung oder widersprüchliche
Erklärungen und lächerlicher Lügen
ermutigt Menschen in der russischen
Gesellschaft egal ob normaler Bürger
Soldat oder Agent zu glauben dass es
überhaupt keine Wahrheit mehr gibt
Protest ist schließlich sinnlos
Engagement nutzlos und dies führt eben
zum überall in Russland anzutreffenden
Zynismus eine weitere Nebenwirkungen
dieses Systems ist natürlich Apathie
Putin hat das Leben der Russen
weitgehend endpolitisiert sich mit der
eigenen Meinung zu beteiligen wird
bestraft der Bürger und das Soldat soll
nur brav seinen Job machen und sich
nicht um Politik kümmern denn das
übernimmt alles Vater Staat unter der
weißen Führung Putin natürlich diese
allgemeine Apathie ist also durchaus vom
Putin Regime gewollt Dom nur das ist ein
Menschen dann eben auch egal lässt wenn
es dem weisenführer an den Kragen geht
denn wenn sich niemand für irgendwas
interessiert bedeutet das dass sie sich
auch nicht für ihren obersten Führer
seine Ideologie oder seinen Krieg
interessiert deswegen sind die Russen
nicht in Scharen gekommen um sich für
den Kampf in der Ukraine zu melden sie
haben sich nicht wie am Vorabend des
Ersten Weltkriegs um die Truppen in der
Ukraine geschadet oder emotional
Philharmonien abgehalten um ihre Erfolge
oder eine Helden tut ihrer Soldaten zu
feiern aber da sie keine Alternative
kennen erzählen sie den
Meinungsforschern brav dass sie Putin
unterstützen und der glaubt das dann
auch noch selber
russische Propaganda meldet Anstieg von
Putins Popularität trotz Wagner der
bakelpropagandisten behaupten dass die
Zustimmungsrate des russischen Diktators
Wladimir Putin nach der Meuterei von auf
90% gestiegen sein und deswegen hat
niemand versucht die Vagina Truppen
aufzuhalten die Sicherheitsorgane taucht
und unterhöhten sich lieber nicht obwohl
Putin die harte Bestrafung der Verräter
befohlen hatte das Militär hob ein paar
Gräben um Moskauer aus zerstörte seine
eigenen Treibstoff unitionsdepots und
schickte ein paar vereinzelte
Hubschrauber die prompt abgeschossen
worden ein paar Lokalpolitiker schickten
bulldose um die Autobahn aufzureißen
aber das war dann auch schon das höchste
der Gefühle das Maximum ein
Opferbereitschaft der Bevölkerung unter
Sicherheitskräfte für dieses Regie ja so
gut wie niemand hatte Bock für Putin zu
sterben und vieles sympathis Aspekten
ganz offen mit pregorian die Absenz der
Streitkräfte Bürste aber auch eine
andere fatale Schwäche Russlands nämlich
dass es über 0 militärische Reserven
verfügt alles was einigermaßen gerade
schießen kann befindet sich an der Front
in der Ukraine das vergangene Wochenende
hat gezeigt dass das einzige was
Russland erlaubt die besetzte Ukraine zu
halten die Tatsache ist dass Kiew
Russland nicht direkt angreifen wird
weil Washington ist noch nicht erlaubt
Amerika ist somit ironischerweise zum
Schutzpatron der russischen Souveränität
geworden sobald jedoch die russische
Truppen mit der Ukraine erstmal
aufgerieben sind gibt es kaum
widerstandsfähige russische Kräfte
zwischen der Grenze und Moskau wenn die
Ukraine die gerade ihre
Rüstungsproduktion massiv hochwertig
dann dazu entschließen würde russisches
Territorium zu besetzen wäre sie nur
schwer aufzuhalten auf jeden Fall viel
schwerer als Wagner natürlich werden
jetzt einige wieder sagen dass Putin in
diesem Fall Atomwaffen einsetzen könnte
aber auch diese Befürchtung hat seit dem
24.06 deutlich an Boden verloren denn
wenn schon jetzt im Fall niemand bereit
war für Putin einen Finger zu krümmen
wieso sollten dies dann die Kommandeure
der strategischen raketenstreitkräfte
tun wie hoch schätzt ihr wo die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass alle in der
nuklearen Befehlskette erforderlichen
Offiziere für Putin bereit wären die
Welt zu vernichten wenn sich jetzt noch
nicht mal reguläre Streitkräfte oder
Geheimdienste für den Opfern wollten der
Putins wird die nukleare Bedrohung durch
Russland nicht erhöhen es sei denn sein
Nachfolger und die militärische
Befehlskette wären selbst mörderischer
als er selbst es ist unwahrscheinlich
das etwas mit dem moskop auf Nasen hat
passiert wenn der Präsident ohne einen
kompletten Wechsel in der Hierarchie der
Streitkräfte abgesetzt wurde eine der
wichtigsten Dinge die die Leute
übersehen wenn sie der ganzen Atom Angst
machen Reihe Glauben schenken ist das
nicht Putin die Befehle gibt sondern die
Streitkräfte die sie innen haben nur
wenn es tatsächlich einen bedeutenden
vollständigen Wechsel in Bezug darauf
gibt wer das Militär und auch die
Atomwaffen leidet könnte etwas passieren
die einzigen Umstände unter denen ist
eine größeres nuklear das Risiko gebe
während wenn jeder in dieser neuen
Befehlskette und der Verwahrung der
Waffen verrückter wäre als Putin es gibt
eine Menge Kontrollen und Gleichgewichte
im System um sicherzustellen dass nicht
ein Verrückter die Atomwaffen abfeuern
lässt keyers Russland und Eurasien
Experte beim Jethelm Haus und der Punkt
ist wir alle haben dies gesehen und auch
Putin hat dies gesehen er weiß nun das
seine Gewalt über die Menschen in
Russland die Armee und damit auch die
Atomwaffen begrenzt ist aber man muss
gar nicht so weit bis zu den Atomwaffen
gehen denn ebenso wurde jedes Argument
man dürfte tut dir nicht in die Ecke
drängen da er sonst unberechenbar würde
durch ihn selbst deutlich widerlegt seit
dem Beginn des russischen einmaliges in
der Ukraine haben Analysten und
Politiker behaupten das Putin ein
knallharte Typ sein der niemals
nachgeben würde dass er einen
gesichtswarenden Sieg brauche das heißt
ukrainisches Territorium um seinen Krieg
beenden zu können aber das alles war nur
ein Mythos den Putin sorgsam über viele
Jahre aufgebaut hat ein Mythos der ihn
viel Macht gab im Innen wie Ausland über
Verbündete wie Gegner und Prägungen hat
diesen mythorst nun weniger Minuten
zerstört er hat den Beweis erbracht dass
das alles an was so viele jahrzehntelang
geglaubt hatten vollkommener Quatsch war
wir müssen ihm dafür eigentlich
unendlich dankbar sein dieser Beweis ist
für die Sicherheit Europas viel mehr
wert als ein erfolgreicher Putsch gegen
Putin der nur wieder einen anderen
Psychopathen an die Spitze Russlands
gespült hätte in seiner ersten Rede zum
Aufstand versprach Putin
unmissverständlich ultimative Härte
gegen die Verräter erklang wie jemand
der sich auf einen großen Kampf
vorbereitet laut Luca Schenker wollte er
pregorian töten lassen doch als er mit
der schwierigen Entscheidung
konfrontiert wurde die Wagner Söldner
durch den Einsatz von Gewalt zu stoppen
machte er einen Rückzieher er hat nicht
eskaliert er brauchte keine
gesichtswarende Ausrede um den Sieg für
sich zu programmieren als er sich mit
dem Risiko eines Blutbads in Moskau oder
gar nicht Verlust ist der Hauptstadt an
die Wagner konfrontiert sah hat er
einfach kapituliert anstatt die Mutter
rein mit noch mehr Gewalt
niederzuschlagen akzeptierte Putin
stattdessen die Demütigung nun versucht
er dies als weise Entscheidung zu
verkaufen und das war sie sicher auch
denn putin hatte keine Option mehr übrig
in der er gewinnen konnte er war die
Ratte die ohne Ausweg in der Ecke
gefangen war das Bild vor dem sich so
viele putinologen jahrelang gefürchtet
haben aber anders als von ihnen immer
vorher gesagt schlug er nicht um sich
und drehte nicht durch er hat behandelt
mit einem Verräter das ist über den
Mittelsmann lukaschenke erfolgte reichte
ihm als Gesichtswahrung laut US
Außenminister blicken wollte Putin sich
wahrscheinlich nicht erniedrigen indem
er direkt mit gregorin verhandelt die
Lektion für den Krieg in der Ukraine ist
also klar putin ist er bereit zu
verhandeln und seinen Krieg zu beenden
wenn er auf dem Schlachtfeld verliert
wenn er oder Ausweg in die Ecke gedrängt
ist die Lösung dieses Krieges liegt also
in der Eliminierung sämtliche Auswege
für Putin und diejenigen die
argumentiert haben dass die Ukraine die
Krim nicht angreifen darf weil sie eine
Eskalation befürchten müssen diese
Orthese nun wirklich ad acta liegen je
früher Putin ernsthaft befürchten muss
dass er den Krieg verliert desto
schneller wird er verhandeln und so
Konzessionen bereit sein das Einzige was
den Krieg verlängern würde wäre noch
mehr Appeasement es ist genau das was
die ehemals von Russland besetzten
Länder in Europa schon die ganze Zeit
erzählt haben dass die Russen im
Angesicht der Schwäche ihrer Gegner
eskalieren und nur im Angesicht starker
Gegner Kompromisse eingehen und genau
aus diesem Grund war pregorians Putsch
für Europa und den Frieden ein
außerordentlicher Erfolg ohne größeres
Blut vergießen hat der Putins macht
durch seine enzauberung mehr geschwächt
als alles zuvor aber natürlich wäre es
überhaupt nicht zu seinem Aufstand
gekommen wenn Russland durch Sanktionen
und die Unterstützung der Ukraine nicht
finanziell in großen Problemen stecken
würde fakt ist also all das hinterlässt
ein Bild von einem Regime das sich im
Verfall befindet und wohlgemerkt es gibt
präsidenzfälle 1991 gelang es dem
sowjetischen Staatschef Michael auch
einen ausstreich zu überleben 20 August
1991 kommunistischer Hardliner putschen
gegen Gorbatschow parasails den Ruf zum
Widerstand auf als der sowjetische
Präsident Michael Gorbatschow unter
Hausarrest gestellt wird Jelzin gelang
ist damals mit ihm treuen Teil der Armee
die Altkommunisten zu schlagen und
Gorbatschow zu retten doch nur vier
Monate später war dieser nicht mehr an
der Macht der Putsch zeigte seine enorme
Schwäche er war von da an nur noch eine
lahme Ente ein Präsident auf Abruf die
wahre Macht im Staate hatte nun der neue
starke Mann Paris stehen wir jetzt also
vor einer ähnlichen Situation darüber
meine Lieben Zuschauer werden wir in den
nächsten Videos über visualpolitik
sprechen also Abo nicht vergessen und da
ihr es zusammen mit mir bis ans Ende
dieses wirklich schwierigen Videos
geschafft habe gibt's jetzt noch einen
kleinen fun fact falls die Meldungen von
der Verhaftung Generation Stimmen und
ich habe gerade gelesen dass eine
Familie angeblich schon seit drei Tagen
nichts mehr von ihm gehört hat wäre er
einer der wenigen generelle die bereits
ein zwei putschen be leicht waren nach
dem Putsch von 1991 gegen Gorbatschow
wurde er nämlich zu sieben Monaten
Gefängnis beurteilt da die von ihm
kommentierte Einheit unter anderem für
den Tod Dreier Bürger verantwortlich war
die sich den Putschisten in den Weg
gestellt hatten ganz genau damals waren
die Bürger der Sowjetunion tatsächlich
bereit ihr Leben für ihren Präsidenten
Gorbatschow zu geben solltest Du ihre
also nun eine putinischen Säuberung zum
opferfall wäre Mitleid fehl am Platze
dieser auch general Armageddon genannte
schlechter ist nicht nur für den Tod
unschuldiger verantwortlich sondern auch
für den unzählige syrischer und
ukrainischer Zivilisten denn wie gesagt
alles worüber wir in diesem Video
gesprochen haben ist ein Armdrücken der
Arschlöcher in der heutigen Geschichte
gibt es keine guten niemanden die man
die Daumen drücken mit dem man
sympathisieren könnte eine traurig
trauriges Geschichte während Drehbuch
jeder Hollywood Produzent sofort in den
Müll werfen würde und in Russland ist
sie Realität so und jetzt seid erstmal
wieder ihr mit eurer Meinung an der
Reihe glaubt ihr dass ich Putin von
kleinen Rückschlägen wird erholen können
oder war dies der Anfang von seinem Ende
was genau wird Wagner nun in Belarus
anstellen und welche Rolle spielt in
dieser ganzen Geschichte der
kartoffeldikator Lukaschenka eigentlich
und was bedeutet das alles eigentlich
für die Sicherheit Europas wie wird sich
das alles auf den Krieg in der Ukraine
ausdrücken nun auch das werden wir in
künftigen Videos unter die Lupe nehmen
aber schreibt uns doch schon mal was
euch einfällt denn wie immer sind wir
schon auf eure Diskussion zu diesem
Thema mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt es bitte ein Like heißt
mit euren Freunden und diskutiert es mit
ihnen natürlich freuen uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
der uns dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video also mach's
gut und bis bald
[Musik]